a traumatic brain injury or TBI is a
disruption in brain function caused by
an external blow to the head and when
you hear that definition you might think
about sports and professional athletes
since it's the kind of injury we're used
to seeing on the playing field and this
imagery has really come to define TBI in
the public consciousness I myself do
research on TBI and retired and college
athletes I stood on a TED stage in 2010
talking about concussions and kids
sports so I have to say as someone who
researches and treats these injuries
that I've been really gratified to see
the growing awareness of TBI and
specifically the short and long term
risks to athletes today though I want to
introduce you to a larger but no less
controversial group of people impacted
by traumatic brain injury who don't
often show up in the headlines I've come
to recognize these inmates and
probationers as surprisingly among the
most vulnerable members of society for
last 6 years my colleagues and I have
been doing research that has completely
changed the way we think about the
criminal justice system and the people
in it and it may change the way you
think about those things too so I'll
start with a shocking statistic 50 to 80
percent of people in criminal justice
have a traumatic brain injury up to 80%
in the general public in this room for
example that number is less than 5
percent and I'm not just talking about
getting your bell rung
these are the kinds of injuries that
require hospitalization most of them are
the product of a physical assault and
some of them are actually sustained in
jail all of these numbers are even
higher among the women in criminal
justice almost every single woman in the
criminal justice system has been exposed
to interpersonal violence and abuse more
than half of these women have been
exposed to repeated brain injuries in
this way these women's brains look like
the brains of retired NFL players and
they'll likely face the same risks for
dementing diseases as they age the same
risks TVI together with mental illness
and substance abuse and trauma makes it
hard for people to think they have
cognitive impairments like poor judgment
and poor impulse control problems that
make criminal justice a revolving door
people get arrested and booked into jail
they oftentimes get into trouble while
they're in there they get into fights
they fall out of their bunk and then
they get released and do stupid things
like forgetting mandatory check-ins and
they get re-arrested statistically
speaking they're actually more likely to
be re-arrested than not a colleague
calls this serving a life sentence 30
days at a time and often times these
folks don't know why this is so hard for
them they feel out of control and
frustrated so knowing that TBI is at the
root of so many of these challenges the
mission for a group of us in Colorado
has been to disrupt that cycle to jam
the revolving door so working together
with my state and local partners we
crafted a plan to meet everyone's needs
the system the inmates and probationers
my graduate students in this program we
assess how each person's brain works
so that we can recommend basic
modifications to make this system more
effective and safer and here when I say
safer I mean safer not only for the
inmates
but safer also for correctional staff in
some ways this is such a simple approach
we're not treating the brain injury
we're treating the underlying problem
that gets people into all of this
trouble in the first place we do quick
neuropsychological screening tests to
identify strengths and weaknesses in the
way in inmate things using that
information we write two reports one a
report for the system with specific
recommendations on how to manage that
inmate the other is a letter to the
inmate with specific suggestions for how
to manage themselves for example if our
test results suggest that a probationer
has a hard time remembering the things
they hear that would be an auditory
memory deficit in that case our letter
to the court might suggest that that
probationer get handouts of important
information and our letter to that
probationer would say among other things
that they should carry a notebook to
record that information for themselves
now most importantly is that I pause
here to be really clear about one point
this program does not minimize
responsibility or make excuses for
anyone's behavior this is about changing
long-standing negative perceptions and
building self-advocacy it's actually
about taking responsibility
the inmates move from I am a total
screwup I'm a loser too here's what I
don't do well and here's what I have to
do about it
[Music]
and the system comes to see an inmate's
problematic behavior as the things they
can't do versus the things they won't do
and that change seeing behavior as a
deficit rather than outright defiance is
everything in these settings we hear
from inmates around the country and they
write and more than anything they want
to know how to help themselves this is
an excerpt from a letter from Troy in
Virginia an excerpt from a 50 page
letter and he writes can you tell me
what you think of all the head traumas
I've dealt with what can I do can you
help me closer to home we have thousands
of stories like this and smart stories
stories that have a great outcome here's
Vinnie Vinnie was hit by a car when he
was 15 and from that moment forward
spent more time in jail than in school
with some basic skill building after our
assessment revealed that he had some
pretty significant memory impairments
Vinnie learned to use the alarm and
reminder function on his iPhone to track
important appointments and he keeps a
checklist to break larger tasks into
smaller manageable ones and with basic
tools like that under his belt Vinnie's
been out of jail for two years clean for
nine months and recently back to work
what's so striking for vini is that this
is his first time off of court
supervision since his injury more than
15 years ago he made it out of the
revolving door
he says now I can do anything I just
have to work a lot harder at it here's
Thomas Thomas has some pretty
significant attention and behavior
problems after an injury landed him in a
coma for more than a month after
relearning how to walk his first stop
court he couldn't imagine a future where
he wasn't in trouble he now carries a
calendar to avoid being held in contempt
for missed court dates and he schedules
a break into his day every day to
recharge before he gets agitated and
nobody knows the revolving door better
than the first and sitting at the front
of the courtroom this is my good friend
and colleague judge Brian Bowen now
judge Bowman was already on a mission to
make the system work for everyone and
when he heard about this program
he saw the perfect fit he actually sits
down with all of his prosecutors to help
them see that there's basically two
categories of defendants in the
courtroom the ones were afraid of
oftentimes rightfully so and the ones
were mad at these are the ones who miss
all of their scheduled appointments and
they blow through the best-laid
probation plans and judge Bowen believes
that with a little more support we could
move people in this latter category the
maddening category through and
ultimately out of the system he proved
that with Navy veteran Mike judge Bowen
saw the correlation between Mike's
history of a massive 70 foot fall and
his long-standing pattern of difficulty
showing up on the right day for court
appointments and complying with
mandatory therapy requirements for
example and instead of sentencing him to
more and more jail time judge Bowen sent
him home with maps and checklists and
handouts and recommended instead
vocational rehabilitation and flexible
scheduling for those therapies and with
those supports Mike's back to work for
the first time
his injury while he was in the service
he's repairing relationships with his
family and just last month he graduated
from Judge Bowens Veterans Court
this program shows us the overwhelming
prevalence of traumatic brain injuries
and cognitive deficits and the
accumulation of brokenness in the
criminal justice system and it
highlights the extraordinary power of
resilience and responsibility in mike
and thomas and vinny even judge Bowen
story use all the transformation made
possible by a change in perception and
some simple accommodations all told in
this program these inmates and
probationers come to see themselves
differently the system sees them
differently and when you meet them in
the community I hope you see them
differently too thanks guys
[Applause]